oh hi and may I just say Happy Easter a
little PSA from those of us here game
life makes sure to wipe all of that
chocolate off of your hands before you
pick up the controller and play this
week's new video games if you haven't
picked up ninja gaiden 3 yet or even if
you have you might want to consider the
new version on shelves this week ninja
gaiden 3 razors edge when tecmo koei
brought their violent ninja action game
to the Wii U last year they gave it more
than a few new features they actually
went in and tweak the gameplay quite a
bit reducing the number of QuickTime
events improving the AI adding three new
playable characters etc etc and now that
the upgraded version is also available
for playstation 3 and xbox 360 for all
you non wii u owners out there and
goodness knows there's a lot of you you
might be familiar with the behemoth the
game developer known for its signature
2d art style in games like alien hominid
castle crashers and nothing else what
what had these guys been doing for the
last four years anyway that oh they've
been working on battleblock theater for
Xbox Live Arcade available on wednesday
it's a single player or cooperative
action game in which you have to
navigate a series of short levels
collecting gems that open up the exits
but there's also a whole list of
competitive multiplayer modes as well in
the works since 2009 there's been a lot
of buildup behind battleblock theater so
let's all hope that it lives up to the
hype finally this week it's the launch
of a major cross media franchise called
defiance the game coming out on Tuesday
is a massively multiplayer online
shooter from Trion Worlds the developer
behind the MMO game rift the show is a
new series debuting April fifteenth on
the sci-fi channel it's not just a new
show with a tie-in game they've actually
been building
both of them together from the beginning
the things that happen during the
episodes of the show will impact the
game and vice versa some characters will
be introduced in the game first and then
appear on TV will it work well a lot of
money a lot of time has been invested
into defiance but maybe players and
viewers will actually get into it we'll
find out this week when defiance
launches on xbox 360 playstation 3 and
and that is this week's bumper crop of
new video games we'll see you next time
on game life